thank you good morning everybody and
welcome to this latest meeting of the
kobe 90 public engagement board in
trafford
can i thank you all for your attendances
i have apologies this morning from nigel
smith sarah radcliffe carl mogul helen
collins councillor chilton and council
lloyd are there any further apologies at
all
don't say anything right thank you we'll
move on of any declarations of interest
in today's agenda
don't see any response to that so can i
just move to the minutes of the last
meeting
uh that was held on the 28th of july and
can i take those as read and a true and
accurate record please thank you
thank you all so we move swiftly on to
the next item which is the update on the
current covered 19 situation in trafford
from uh director of public health
eleanor rove eleanor
hi hi everyone so um currently
while we've seen a big reduction in our
cases since the beginning of july week
that reduction has now stopped slowed
down and in fact we're now starting to
see an increase in cases again in
trafford and that's being mirrored
across um the rest of great a number of
other boroughs in greater manchester as
well so we're not seeing a dramatic
increase at the moment but it is it is
an increase um
in particular it's we're seeing it in
our 19 to 24 year olds
um and also a little bit of an increase
in the 30 to 44 populations which both
of those groups had the highest rates
anyway so those are our our younger
working age populations
where we're really seeing that increase
in rates
um obviously although the majority of
people in both groups have been
vaccinated um our fifth uh um 19 to 24
year olds have only just been eligible
for that first vaccine and are just
coming up to the dates where they can
start having that second that second
dose
so as i say although the majority of of
people in that age group has been
vaccinated we still do have a gap there
we've got a gap while they wait to have
that second dose
and give them to give them that full
protection but we also do need to see
the rates increase in uptake vaccination
in that younger age group we're still
waiting to get guidance on whether when
the 16 and 17 year olds will be eligible
for vaccinations so that that will be
coming through and we're hoping to get
the first doses into that age group
before term starts again um and we're
talking to local colleges and so on
about where where best facts offer
vaccination for those people
um rebecca will be talking i'm sure more
about the the vaccination program um but
at the moment i would be definitely
saying to people um please don't delay
most people in your age group are now
vaccinated if you haven't been
vaccinated yet do do um do take the
opportunity um if we can get more people
vaccinated in august that would be
fantastic because we know september is
going to be busy so if you can get your
vaccine in early you'll get more choices
slots if you can go in
in august so so please don't delay at
all with that vaccination
um
we are getting a number of changes
obviously coming in and and just on the
spread so our rates of nearly 300 per
hundred thousand still um so you know it
is significant but we are seeing as very
fortunately the vaccination is working
well
um and it is stopping that
hospitalization and deaths
but
the vaccine can't do everything on its
own we really do need to support it no
vaccine is 100 effective and you can
still become ill and you can still give
other people um covered if you're
infected even after you've been
vaccinated so we'd really urge people to
continue to be quite cautious every ward
in the borough has rates over 120 per
hundred thousand
um and that's not unusual across the
whole of greater manchester
so at the moment i would say to people
please go and get that vaccine but
please can we all continue to do
everything we can to help the vaccine
work and not to put too much pressure on
it
because it isn't 100 effective so please
take extra care meet people outside if
you can if you if you're in a household
with somebody who's infected um from
next uh monday even if you're fully
vaccinated you wouldn't need to
self-isolate but i would really urge
people to to continue to treat covid
with respect it can create a very nasty
illness still
and so please do be very very cautious
and
don't go you know think about the risks
you might pose to people who might not
have good health if you do go out and
about after the 16th um if you've been a
contact of somebody who's been back
who's infectious so um and and do
remember that you could still spread
covert even if you've been vaccinated so
i think over the summer i would urge
people to continue to be very cautious
continue to and particularly in places
like supermarkets you know give people
space wear your face coverings make not
everybody there may be in good health so
so respect everybody's need for that
little bit of additional space around
them and and keep our infection rates
down and don't worry people i think you
know people are still getting very some
people are still very worried about
covert it's really important that people
get out and about get start getting back
to a normal life but if you like a
cautious normal life a slightly
different normal life over the summer
let's get on top of this um and not go
mad tr you know
the rates are still high and we don't
want anyone ill who doesn't need to be
um so that that i think is my update
thank you very much eleanor are there
any questions from anyone for eleanor
[Music]
around the spread of
if you've had the you know two jabs um
how i spreaded it um that you can
actually spread
um you know the
the covert if you have got it
um
and
yeah i i just wonder you know
how many people percentage-wise
are spreading it do we know that
i don't think we've got exact figures on
it what we do know is that you're most
infectious when you're um when you have
symptoms and particularly when you have
fever so it's definitely the disease
that can be spread asymptomatically
but is most infectious at the point when
people have the most symptoms so that's
the point of which people need to be
absolutely careful even if you've been
double vaccinated and so on if you've
got any symptoms you must stay at home
you must self-isolate and you could give
it to other people in your household
quite easily at that point if you've
been double vaccinated and you're living
in a household with somebody who's
infectious and has and has symptoms like
that
you you might have very mild symptoms
but we do or or no symptoms but we do
know that it's something that can be
spread asymptomatically so the
vaccination definitely provides
protection because it will take you from
being
potentially very infectious to
potentially being a little bit
infectious
and that and we do know as well that the
protections we take in what in terms of
wearing face coverings in terms of
meeting people outdoors
give keeping that social distancing
all of those things are really effective
at keeping infection rates down so what
i'd be saying to people is if you um if
i if somebody in my household was
infectious um
i wouldn't go you know that that i would
not go to any set i would really try and
minimize who i saw and what i did um i
might you know i i could still go to the
supermarket but i would be absolutely
sure to make sure that i didn't go near
anyone in there you know try not to
touch things that i don't want to buy
etc etc so it's really treating i think
it's just that you could still be
infectious so just be that bit more
cautious
the rules change on on uh monday and
that i think is you know there's many
good good things about the rules
changing but i think the thing we need
to understand with those rules changing
is the nature of infection and the
nature of how you catch an infectious
disease doesn't change so what we need
to be doing is being just because the
law has changed doesn't mean that we
should change our behaviors we we do
know that covid is something that does
keep coming back that can get variance
and obviously if it meets somebody
vaccinated and then
mutates that could be real trouble for
us also i think it's just trying to
limit the number of people at the moment
that we um that we that are exposed to
this disease
partly because of the unpredictable
nature of it you know especially i would
say this to younger people almost all
younger people have it as a very mild
disease and may not have any serious
consequences but we do know some people
are seriously ill and we have even seen
deaths in that younger age group the
rate is really really low but every
death
now when you can be vaccinated you know
every death is a tragedy isn't it and if
if there's ways that they can be
prevented we need to be doing that so
part of that prevention is vaccination
and part of that prevention is thinking
about how we behave and how we make sure
that we we don't cause a risk to
ourselves or other people
i think gradually as we get more
evidence and particularly um we will
start you know we'll be able to start
assessing more clearly how many people
are are um catching it when when
vaccinated and how infectious they might
be i would say them the the big concerns
are going to be in households household
infections so really making sure that
you you know as you would if somebody
had um diarrhoea and vomiting in the
house you do what you would make real
care that you didn't um get too close
and that you were scrupulous and hygiene
in those situations we should be doing
the same with covid
and the other places i would be really
you know we're really advising people to
take all the precautions they're
currently taking is obviously um when
working with anyone in their care home
home care setting visiting any of those
settings you know please be very very
cautious in those settings
thank you
any further questions at all
is that catherine want to come in no
no i don't think right well we'll move
on then to the next which is a
self-isolation pathfinder update invite
kirsty johnson to update us kirsty
hi good morning um
so
this is the pathfinder that has been
running from april and it's due to run
until mid-september time
and this is where we've been proactively
calling people in a geographical
location within trafford
um it's been m15 and m16 postcodes
to see if they need any support while
self-isolating
so it's about having that proactive
asset based conversation
and
promoting the phone call to the people
in those areas and just making sure that
they're aware of what support is on
offer in trafford
so in that phone call we support um we
promote what support is on offer and
that might be the 500 pound
self-isolation payment
the existing welfare schemes that we
have in place across trafford so the
welfare provision are in gas and
electricity food and
working with the community hubs and also
identifying any other support needs that
that people
might have or that might occur during
that telephone call
so to date we've reached 690 people so
that's a mixture of those who require
support so they've said yes to the
national team during that contact
tracing call
and also those were we've done that
targeted calling and we have identified
a support need
so this week we've rolled it out a
little bit wider
across the borough into m32 and m33
postcodes so we've found just some of
the case rates have dropped we've been
able to take on that extra capacity in
this support call that we can offer
people
and and we've supported uh people in 96
households so that's in addition to
your existing schemes such as the
welfare scheme and the sit payments this
is an additional 96 people who we've
identified through that proactive call
and that conversation where we've
identified that they need support
in the main it still remains um food
support that people might need or
they're interested in the existing
financial support scheme that's on
offer now all this feeds into a gm wide
initiative that then feeds up to the
national team
so some local authorities are now coming
towards the end of the pathfinder and
there's an external evaluation of it so
what we're currently working on at the
minute is what's what's gone well what
do we need to learn from this what's
going less well
to what extent do people feel the path
finders meeting its intended aims
and what are the overall outcomes and
what have they been which will then feed
into the national team which will
hopefully support
um similar work in the future or how
individuals might be supported in the
future um through the throughout the
remainder of the pandemic
so that's where we're up to at the
minute i'll continue to update on that
wider evaluation and the initiatives
that are going on um across all local
authorities and feed some of them
outcomes into the meeting
thank you
before i throw them into questions
if we're at the evaluation stage and and
various pathfinder initiatives are
coming to an end do we expect there to
be additional funding coming forward
from the government for this to continue
um so not for this pathfinder it doesn't
look like there'll be any additional
funding
um in terms of the self-isolation
payment the 500 pound grant and the
discretionary scheme i believe that's
there's nothing been agreed
um further than the end of august
but we normally kind of hear last minute
on that and then it it you know it's a
it's a little bit late in the day so i'm
not sure where
whether that would be extended that has
continued to be expense extended so the
deadline was march initially and then we
got in august it got extended till
august so i think we just need to wait
in here on that one
i suppose one of the things there is it
really depends on what the infection
rates are like at that particular point
and i do take your point about the last
minute decisions that are being made are
there any questions at all for kirsty
from any of our
attendees
well kirsten
yes elena sorry i was just going to say
i think the real power of this is is
it's trying to make sure that in
particular in areas where we know that
there might be real um barriers to
self-isolation because of um funding
difficulties it really is trying to make
sure that we've got that offer and so i
really hope we do continue to get
funding for this because i think as we
go through the autumn and winter we're
likely to see
covert as um
more cases of covid but potentially
longer term we'll be seeing
more cases in areas where you've got
people doing more face-to-face work on
lower incomes and so on and more you
know so anything we can do to support
that group of people to self-isolate is
going to be really helpful in making
sure we get on top of the disease so i
really do hope
again as i say as numbers come down it
should be easier to put that funding
into the the areas where we absolutely
know that we need to to be providing
that additional support to people to do
that
self-isolation um so so i i hope we do
continue to see that
thank you elena and uh thank you kirsten
for that update okay
moving swiftly on then um
mass testing
good morning ben
good morning chair um so i've got a few
testing updates for you all this morning
uh the first one around new testing
technology so i mentioned a little bit
about this um the other week um but
we've now got two new types of lateral
flow tests and we've now got a bit more
detail about them so the first is called
um
flowflex made by a company called acon
and the second is called the orient gene
they're both purely nasal swabs now so
they don't require a throat swab as well
so if you're anything like me and you
tend to cry every time you do a swab
then that's a good thing
um
both of them have the solution that come
in the test tube and crucially both only
require 15 minutes so they've half the
time it takes to get results which is
obviously really positive news so the
difference between the two is that acorn
is for home tests and the own gene is
for on-site testing
and there may also be more manufacturers
a lot of flow tests coming down the line
we're told but they're the two
um ones that you'll start to see soon
so connected to this when it comes to
schools and secondary schools have been
asked to retain a few lots of the nova
kits just in case anyone does require
throw only solves because they can't
test via their nose
um but otherwise they're going to be
using the orient gene for their on-site
testing when pupils return um that will
be um two on-site tests that secondary
pupils will have to do and then they
will move to home testing throughout
september and again we've had
confirmation now that those home test
lbs will be the account flow flex ones
so the other update i wanted to give was
around workplace daily contact testing
um for closed contacts so as you may be
aware there are two kind of systems the
first one before the 16th forecast so
that's for workplaces who employs
critical workers who have had to go for
that relevant
department so for example if it's a food
manufacturer they would have gone
through deferred um and once they've had
it confirmed um we've now been made
aware they need to go direct to public
health so in this case eleanor um know
this so we've had one so far come let us
know
um and then after the 16th of august
where close contacts with double
vaccinated only need that ptr test so we
have been told that workplace daily
conduct testing is going to continue in
some form probably for those that are
not double vaccinated but we are still
waiting for more details about that
and then the final thing just in terms
of some kind of key messages um just
that we're going to be really really
encouraging um 16 for those high
consequence settings to make sure
they're continuing to test regularly so
specifically you know the likes of home
care care homes etc um and
um i guess crucial and i know i say it's
every week but it is the most important
thing that can be done in terms of
testing messaging is that still continue
to get a pcr test even if you only have
mild symptoms as eleanor mentioned
before you are most infectious when you
have symptoms so it's really really
important if you do have any of those
growth symptoms go and get yourself a
pcr test
and that's all for me
ben thank you before i throw up to
questions the new types of tests you've
described will they become available at
chemists
so they should so obviously at the
moment yeah you can go and get your home
test through um through chemists we
expect to go and see them filter through
it's all going to be around kind of
stockerville um stock hole so if certain
pharmacies have a lot of innova kits
left they're still going to be handing
out those in other ones like i said the
the first ones the first
time we definitely expect the acorn ones
to come through are going to be for
second school pupils but we expect that
pharmacies will start to collect those
as they run through the innova kits
and the second question is probably not
your area but it's we were talking about
the need for people to be to be
vaccinated of course the government of
uh legislated that if you work in a care
home you need to be more vaccinated
um how are we coping with that uh in
trafford at the moment uh are we
are we getting there
i wanted to
yeah so
so we are um and rebecca i'm sure we'll
talk more on this we've obviously been
focusing on um vaccination for care home
staff and care home residents right from
the very start um and the ccg have been
um running special clinics making sure
that people get that vaccination taken
out to them there are a couple um the
care homes are fully aware of the
requirements um for the with the law
changing um to make sure that everybody
not only who works in the care home but
actually all um all paid staff who visit
so for example anybody any of our gp's
any district nurses other staff who are
going to the care homes so we've made
sure all of the our local health
services and social care are all making
sure that their staff are appropriately
vaccinated to go in there there's a
couple of care homes i think where we've
we've had
a slightly lower uptake but we've seen
an improvement in that over over the
last few weeks so we are continuing to
make sure that care home staff have
quick and easy access to vaccination
and
i mean
obviously
this is one of the few vaccines that is
compulsory
and that there's there is a lot of
debate about whether that's the right
way to go but this is the law so we are
absolutely making sure that we're
abiding by it i think it will be
interesting to see
um
how how that plays out
over you know over time in in this um
but we we are we are absolutely making
sure that we are working with the care
homes to reduce the risk of any staff
not being able to work because of not
being vaccinated
and our care homes are such a massively
important system to us um you know
they've worked so hard through the whole
of the pandemic i think i've said this
many times on the call our care home
sector have been absolutely fabulous um
so and they are absolutely focused on
keeping their residents safe
thanks helena um are there any questions
more widely for for ben at all
i don't see any so thank you very much
indeed ben
uh we'll move on then to uh contact uh
tracing and and outbreak management uh
kate good morning
good morning thanks chair um just a
brief update from myself today as we're
all aware the the regulations around
isolation are changing as of monday
um we are just awaiting the final
guidance from the government about how
we're going to verify those who do need
to isolate and those who don't
so anybody who's had um
completed the vaccination program the
two doses of vaccine
and more than two weeks before being a
contact of a positive case
anybody under the age of 18
anybody who cannot be vaccinated for
medical reasons and anybody who's been
on a vaccine trial will be exempt from
isolation moving forward
and but we do want to make sure as
eleanor said that we're getting the
messaging right about still being
cautious you know if you have been a
contact of a case we would still advise
precautionary behaviors around limiting
social contact and keeping distance
our
activity around
the complex
settings our level one contact tracing
is a little bit quieter at the moment
we're still engaging with lots of
businesses and are planning to work very
proactively with businesses as the
regulations change and we link very
closely with ben um around identifying
businesses that can be supported with
testing
and we expected our activity to quieten
off just at this time because schools
and colleges are closed at the moment
that's not because those settings are
more risky it's just because of the
sheer numbers of people that access them
and our level two referrals continue to
run fairly highly and at the moment
we're currently in the process of
recruiting for a bespoke team of contact
tracers previously our contact chasing
activity has been supported by many
different teams across the local
authority which we're very grateful for
but as they have returned to business as
usual there's more stretches on that
capacity
so we are currently recruiting for a
specialist team of contact tracers
and the plans for that team will mean
that we will be able to tailor contact
tracing much more specifically in
trafford at the moment the contact
tracing that we do for the level twos
which is the positive cases are only the
cases that the national test and trace
team haven't been able to reach within
the first 24 hours
what we would hope to do with our
specialist team
is to move to be able to taking the
contact tracing for all positive cases
dependent on capacity and even expand
expand that to some contacts as well
um and and hopefully this will improve
the experience for people being contact
traced because for example if we're
speaking to one family member we can
just carry on with all the contact
chasing for the rest of that family and
advise the contacts accordingly so
they're the plans for moving forward for
contact chasing
thank you kate any questions at all for
kate
i don't see any so thank you very much
and we'll move on then to rebecca on
mass vaccination good morning rebecca
am i there good morning chair sorry
about that i'm having an intermittent um
internet problem so um thanks everybody
nice to see you all and i'd just like to
kind of i suppose start by reiterating
what um everybody has said prior to this
and particularly eleanor so
no vaccine is ever 100
effective that is not unusual and it is
not um kind of specific to the covid
vaccine it is highly effective and we
need to continue pushing that message um
but it would not provide a kind of
shield of steel to everybody as no other
vaccine would so um just to reiterate
that and remind people to be cautious
but um the message is it is highly
effective
um so as always i will start with the um
numbers so um in terms of total numbers
of um vaccine doses delivered as of the
10th of august we've now got over 308
000 and first and second doses we have
um 82
of the total eligible cohort which is 18
plus who have had their first dose and
72 of that cohort who have had their um
first and second dose
in terms of our most vulnerable patients
um which were cohorts one to nine we're
now at 92 percent of uh vulnerable
patients who have had first and second
dose
um and i was asked a question last time
about the 18 to 30s so the current
percentage of 18 to 30s to have had
their first dose is at 64 so we're
nearly at two-thirds and that's all
based on registered population so that's
patients registered with a traffic gp
there will always be a discrepancy with
the um public health data which is about
um residents rather than um registered
as eleanor mentioned we are expecting
imminently now the guidance to be issued
in terms of the 16 to 17 year olds um
broadly so currently 16 to 17 year olds
who are clusters clinically extremely
vulnerable
are contacted to be offered the vaccine
but we are expecting that wider guidance
um
to be published imminently in terms of
the 16 to 17 year olds and that will
very much determine our plan for um
colleges sixth form colleges trafford
college and others and and have a bit of
an approach for that from september so
that's been taken forward with um input
from public health um through the
vaccine board
um so once that guidance is published
and formalized we will um come back to
you with um what our plans are around
the 16 to 17 year olds
august is a little bit quieter in terms
of our big events and pop-up clinics
just because as elena said it's a
generally acquired period with annual
leave and um people on holiday and
schools and college is not in so we're
just using august really to plan for
um
both the 16 to 17 year old guidance and
also the booster
so in terms of the booster which is
known as the phase 3
part of the program
all five of our networks from a primary
care perspective have expressed an
interest in delivering phase three and
flu so that's five networks and six
sites
our existing three pharmacies who have
provided um
vaccination delivery over phase two have
also expressed an interest in booster
and flu and we have also supported an
additional four pharmacies across
trafford to deliver phase three and flu
and i won't name them now because at the
this point in time it's just an
expression of interest and they've not
been confirmed but those four additional
sites are based on areas where we've um
had over the last 12 months um
challenges in terms of uptake so that's
about expanding um access and ensuring
that we've got as much um provision as
possible um in those areas so that's
where we're at so that's a really good
position to be in for phase three
um just in terms of the care homes
question which came up um in the last
conversation so very closely working
with our public health and local
authority colleagues from a ctg
perspective to
um
identify those care homes where we've
got um less up-taking staff
the legislation which has been passed
has seen um
we've we've seen an an
improvement in terms of our uptake in
staff
and so that is being shown now in terms
of the numbers that we're seeing
in terms of staff vaccinations and we
are now working on specifically um
awareness raising sessions with those
homes who who have still got
numbers of staff who are hesitant and
also sharing with all of our homes the
walk-in and pop-up clinics and all of
the access points so that staff are able
to access wherever they want not
necessarily just taking the um vaccine
into the homes
and so that's where we're up to at the
moment and i'll pause there and happy to
take any questions
thank you rebecca any questions uh at
all um
yeah yeah what counts accordingly is it
or cancer acting first
yeah thanks chair um
with regard to the booster
um
obviously you would have had two jobs um
to get a booster uh
is it the same
vaccine that you use that you've used
previously
so we've not yet had the final
specification and so the guidance
formally isn't out yet
to enable me to answer that question as
finally however the indications suggest
that pfizer will be the um booster
vaccine of choice because of its
increased protection against the delta
variant so that's what we're hearing but
that's not been formalized yet and so it
doesn't necessarily need to be the same
vaccine as you've had for doses one and
two
thank you uh council accordingly
uh thanks chair um
just a a quick observation um
looking at the um
the daily figures that are on the uh
public health um
the nhs um i think it's public health uh
website
um
the area with the highest vaccine uptake
is template which coincides with
the area that i see
i see the best publicity for their
drop-in centers
um
so they're there
it's almost on a daily basis that i see
some publicity for lark hill dropping um
and that also is our best performing
area so i i i really think um
you know that
they're showing the way and the more we
can copy that by making getting really
good publicity about dropping centers
for better because it
it seems pretty obvious that that is
making a difference there's no reason
why temporary should be outperforming
the hail for instance otherwise um so i
i think
i welcome the news that you're giving
about the new sites that are coming with
the booster
and that will help but um
the areas that with the least publicity
for dropping is old trafford and ghost
hill and we're at the bottom and
i can't help putting the two and two
together um so
that's my observation and
it'll take a lot to dissuade me that the
drop-in centers don't work and good
publicity about them
thank you councillor i do not disagree
at all so we do now have a weekly
publication of all drop-in and walk-in
centers which does include sites within
the north of the borough including the
limelight um and other places within the
north and but comment taken if we need
to publicize those a little bit more and
do some more proactive work then
absolutely we shall do that and i will
pick that up with the um community
engagement team so thank you
can i just come back on that
yeah can i just come back on that um
limelight is great but if
it
it's
for one area of old trafford i i i
suppose my ambition to sort of top this
off in terms of vaccinations and really
get it is more in the north more than
just uh limelight so
there's a big area between stratford and
old trafford
where we could do with something i mean
we call them walking censors but a good
reason that you walk to them if you
can't walk to limelight from
most of ghost hill and uh london really
um so yeah i'm after mall really and i
know we've used the cricket ground but
um
if we can get more in
that's been very much linked to matches
and it
it doesn't feel as though it's a sort of
regular um
occurrence
we also used council accordingly the
town hall for the uh cricket and when
the pre-season game against brentford
and that was an all-day
walk-in and that was quite i'm led to
believe very successful i do take your
point on what's being said but uh i'll
let you rebecca
thank thank you chair so um again
without without naming sites because it
wouldn't be fair at this stage until
we've had formal confirmation but
absolutely based on um council
accordingly speed bike that has been the
basis of which we have um supported
additional expressions of interest from
additional sites in the north of the
borough
so and
that's exactly what we've done but as i
say i don't want to share those names at
the moment until they are confirmed by
nhs england but that's absolutely what
we've done so i hope that gives you some
assurance thank you yes it does
thank you very much for that
thank you council accordingly uh
councillor new grosh thank you
councillor um so i i have a question and
a comment on the uh kill so the question
i've got is on the booster programme do
we know the cohorts that are going to be
offered that so we are they set yet and
and on the lark kill we've really driven
it we when we hear there's um an excess
of a vaccine at the center the local
councillors on social media really push
that um and cause well we've caused
traffic jams with the demand um once
they've known it's there so
there's a it's a big team effort that
that gets lark hill
well finished on a day of her
vaccination but uh it's a you know we're
very proud of it
um so thank you and it would be really
great to do that same local um
publicity and real drive for some of our
other sites but um i do thank you for
your efforts with um like hill in terms
of the booster and the eligible cohorts
yes we have had indicative guidance of
the um clients who will be um
prioritized for the booster vaccine and
it will be very similar to those
priority cohorts um which were at the
beginning so that includes um our over
80s um health and social care frontline
workers those who are clinically
extremely vulnerable so it's a very
similar
um priority list for the booster as it
was for um dose one
um as i say the specifications not yet
been published but that is the um cohort
that we're looking at and it links very
closely to the eligible cohort for flu
um which are similar and and again we've
not had the final guidance yet but we
are anticipating that the
um kobe booster and flu may be
administered at the same time uh with
the same cohort of people but until that
guidance is formally published that's
just um
what what we believe to be the case at
the moment
thank you
thank you council mugross jilla you've
got a question
thank you chair um it wasn't a question
it was just to add to rebecca's
assurance around
the
promotion of clinics and other
opportunities in the north of the
borough just to say
that
i chair the vaccine equity group that
meets
weekly and
we
use
those meetings to look at the uptake
data and then to
steer the work of the community
engagement team
and the operational group
to
try to focus resources um on those areas
with lowest uptake so i will pick up
your comments we'll discuss
what more we can do to increase
promotion of clinics and indeed the
supply of clinics in the north of the
borough
in that meeting
thank you very much indeed that's very
reassuring are there any further
questions at all
thank you rebecca for uh your update as
usual thank you thank you
uh and we move on to uh community
engagement and welcome catherine
o'connor who's standing in today for
nigel smith welcome catherine
nice to meet you all thank you
and so i'm going to give an update on
our summer program primarily um our
summer program is running for four weeks
throughout august and we're spending a
week in each of the four different
neighbours at neighbourhoods of trafford
and so our program called shape up for
summer is around promoting general
messaging of living a healthy lifestyle
this summer in order to reduce the risks
from covert 19 and other diseases
we've been promoting it via our team's
networks by the council's social media
by the community hubs and also gps
we launched last monday in the central
neighborhoods that's some of the areas
around sale and in that area last week
we engaged with 143 people in the
community across three different venues
which was particularly impressive given
the bad weather at the tail end of the
week when we were doing events outdoors
um so far this week uh we've been in the
west in passington we engaged with 91
people on monday and a really good
community fun day there were lots of
groups there lots of activities
also meeting
so with period poverty so they were
present uh distributing sanitary
products we're else again today in
partington at the wellbeing center
and and we're out in old trafford and
stratford in the north next week and
simply an ultra in the south following
so so far that's engaging with 234
people and hopefully many more to follow
um their activities and conversations
have been well received by the public
we've had lots of interaction
particularly families
we've been putting on some physical
activities which kids in particular have
been getting involved in
lots of community building
and we just wanted to say a big thank
you as well to some of the community
volunteers we've had in particular in
parsington pride of parties we've been
great uh to help facilitate so thank you
sharon dawn and lisa
some initial findings from our
engagement and we found that the
majority of people have felt safe and
been glad to be out and about doing more
although some people still experiencing
significant anxiety and worries about
coverage as well as related stresses
things like redundancy other health
worries
so it really highlighted the importance
of elmer's point familiar around being
mindful and respectful of people's
different levels of comfort and worries
about their own health
we found some people still experiencing
social isolation particularly those
working at working from home still
and people wanting clarification around
travel guidance
people have been receiving the healthy
lifestyles discussion positively some of
them have shared their own stories about
their journey to improving their health
uh mentioned things like having
additional time to exercise during
lockdown and while working from home
and so that was really positive and
again delivering that messaging around
healthy lifestyles in order to improve
resilience from covert and other
diseases
and as well as that we're continuing to
recruit and get messages out by our
community champions network and we're
linked in with the group that dilla
discussed around
vaccine equity
and improving vaccine access and
confidence
so we're particularly working with youth
groups so 1830s
it will be linking in with key venues
over the next few weeks like bars and
clubs and we're also looking at doing
some engagement by the traffic centre
either at the end of this month or the
start of september
thank you catherine are there any
questions at all for catherine
i don't see if i just say
thank catherine and the community
engagement team for the work that they
are doing i think it's a really really
um essential that we just get the
message out the way that we are doing
and i've certainly been out with the
community engagement team i know my
colleague liz patel uh has also been out
with them and i'm really impressed with
the work that is going on here so so
thank you very much
thank you i'll pass that on to the team
that's great to hear
thank you um is there any other business
at all
i don't see we're getting through these
meetings a lot quicker these days um can
i click close by thanking again our
public health teams uh environmental
health and all our staff that are
engaged in in driving down the infection
rates in trafford and trying and and
assisting in helping to combat this
awful uh uh
pandemic that we've been going through
uh we meet again in the fortnight's time
um and uh until then if you're going on
holiday or going awake and i wish you
all
a happy holiday um
in the meantime i will see you again in
two weeks time and thank you for your
attendance today